take you downstairs to the Washington
Redskins locker room and here's Lesley
Visser Leslie Gregg it truly is hail to
the Redskins as they delivered their
third title in ten years to the nation's
capital
it's a jubileus scene in here high
spirits and that was Lesley Visser of
CBS sports in 1992 becoming the first
woman to present the Vince Lombardi
Trophy at the Super Bowl Leslie has
broken barriers from more than 40 years
in the male-dominated field of sports
reporting in 1995 she was the first
woman to report from the sidelines of
the Super Bowl she became the only woman
enshrine in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame in 2006 and in 2009
Wester became the first female NFL
analyst on TV that resume she's still
going visitor that's covered 35 Super
Bowls 35 NCAA Final Fours and 10
Olympics she's also a contributor to We
Need to Talk on CBS Sports Network the
first nationally televised all-female
sports show Visser's new book is called
sometimes you have to cross when it says
don't walk a memoir of breaking barriers
she shares her struggles and triumphs
over her groundbreaking journey in
sports and Lesley Visser is joining us
now
you've just brightened up our house oh
it's great to have say it all again
seeing what you've accomplished as a
woman out in an industry where your mom
told you
you know you sometimes you have to cross
when it says don't walk because there
were no women in that field how do you
feel today now looking at what you've
accomplished do you know I remember our
great John Madden who of course works
worked with CBS for so many years and
you know John said it's a strange thing
now you guys live this world -
congratulations - but you guys love this
he said it's a strange thing when you go
from being the observer to the observed
yeah and so that's what I'm much more at
home asking you guys about your
background I loved your show you knew
you wanted to do this at 11 years old I
did I never stopped my mother we lived
in Cincinnati at the time we moved a lot
as a kid which was great for sports and
I said to my mother I was like 10 maybe
or 11 I said
you know what I want to be a sports
writer and my mother instead of at that
time women were only three things you
know nurses teachers or homemakers yeah
and my mother instead of saying what are
you crazy she said to me great sometimes
you have to cross when it says don't
walk so it truly it was not an easy
journey to get from that 11 year old to
where you are now talk about the doubt I
mean your mother was obviously an
empower empowered you in a lot of ways
but how much skepticism did you meet
along the way when you said this is what
I want to do Oh plenty I was just
sharing with someone that of course when
I started there were no ladies rooms
because there were no other women and
you know what's the great movie hidden
figures yeah we're Kevin Costner says
sir you know where do you go for 40
minutes well that was my life I used to
sit in the Patriots press box first and
ten Patriots on their own 20 and I would
say do I have time to go down the
elevator across to the only public
restroom and get back before the
Patriots punted so so yeah but I I tried
to do steamer was my default Mack I know
what you guys use my humor was mine and
that's how you got through it that's how
I got through it and other people use
other mechanisms but for me humor worked
when you see when you when you talk to
kids you want to go into this business
today what do you say and and about how
things have changed you know I just want
people to like you guys have a passion
for what you do you know if you don't
love it don't do it so if I just love
sports I maybe you guys growing up I
don't know did you good now I want to do
other kids you know they love music
right or they love poetry or I just
loved sports but I don't know what can
kind of you you guys tougher
what were the tough when you when you
were going through all of this and
breaking these barriers what were the
most difficult sports to cover I was a
natural baseball because I grew up
loving the Red Sox and we only got
obnoxious lately you know we used to be
pathetic so so I was I was naturally a
baseball fan
and then I've had the privilege of
writing John Madden's bus with him and
we would watch the Redskins counter tray
over and over and over on the footage
and so I I just never all I've stood for
for myself is to be authentic yeah and I
think basketball is easy for people to
fall in love with you know it's just ten
people on the court but you know
football is complicated for follow it
might look easy
you know this might by the way I was at
the last Jacksonville I did that game
all you were yes I was and do you
remember oh no you don't want to
remember I know I don't want to but it
was the last play wasn't it of the game
yes unfortunately no you're back at him
so we talked about the most difficult
sports to cover who did you learn from
the most talking to folks you talked
about Madden a lot who else did you
learn from you know CBS we've had all
the greats I mean you know we we had
Madden and summer all we had Verne
Lundquist you know and I would say this
now our les Moonves the you know he has
now created this show and the women we
need to talk we really talked ball yeah
he'd love it Jeff we've seen it yes
Sports is a vehicle and many times for
storytelling in general and you've
witnessed some of the most historic
events good sad that we've seen in
sports and in the world you covered the
1972 Munich Olympics and the murder of
the Israeli athletes you covered the
fall of the Berlin Wall in 89 what were
those experiences like oh thanks for
asking that the Berlin Wall my dad grew
up in Amsterdam was not Jewish but under
the Nazi occupation so to be sent to the
fall of the Berlin Wall was so profound
you know people you guys know this they
walk for days right to get through the
Brandenburg Gate and I was just one of
many people from CBS and my little slice
of the pie was how will sports change
cuz member the great Katarina vit oh yes
he's Joe so so she was yeah so that was
my little slice of the pie but I wrote
this book because I wanted to be anyone
who has a dream no your guys dream was
what was yours to play for the bills but
don't happen Leslie it is an amazing
story you waiting out in those ice-cold
parking lots to interview players not
having a ladies room my how things have
changed Lesley Visser you are a hero
it's a great book thank you for your
time Congrats Oh sometimes you have to
cross when it says don't walk is on sale
now